I'm really excited and honored to be
presenting today
um
my past and the present work on
multi-material design for miniature
robots but before I start talking about
the miniature robots I would like to
give you give you um kind of what
actually inspired me to build this
miniature robots and how I kind of
basically build up on that philosophy of
small scale animals so first
one of those animals is is ants so ants
is very abundant in the nature and they
can do incredible stuff collectively so
they can build Bridges they can build
towers even float like a boat and also
teach each other each other for example
and more experienced and can teach a
less experience and how to find food for
example for foraging
but little known
about so it's a lot known about their
Collective behaviors but they are not
only Collective super organisms they can
also have they also possess incredible
individual mechanisms for example
have you seen a flying ant
or
this is not actually a kind of
reverse video and falling down
have you seen a jumping end
navigating through cluttered Forest
environments
so this incredible creature is called
trap Giant
they developed Over The evolutionary
process an incredible
mechanism for coping with environment as
well as escaping Predators so they use
this
miniature mechanism that
Joel and use it for for multifunctional
purpose so they just not only catch the
prey but they can also flip and then
jump to escape Predators
but also they could use their legs not
only for crawling but also using it for
jumping in in a cluttered environment
so
this robot could Inspire us to build
more capable miniature robots and this
robots could be deployed in mass and
then they could start work working
together
they could navigate fairy cluttered very
difficult environment they could
communicate toward a common task
so even if some of them would fail
it wouldn't hinder them to accomplish
the task so it's really kind of a
low-cost mass-producible systems but
obviously building this robot is
challenging in terms of miniaturization
for example
embedding multi-functionality to their
mechanical design but also manufacturing
them in Mass
let's look at the robot design across
scales so when we look at the on my left
side on the micro scale we could achieve
an amazing kind of progress in
developing
robots that could be stationary that
could be on Wheels they could be flying
around thanks to the advancement in
electromechanical actuation systems and
modern manufacturing processes
when we look at the microscale and these
robots were inspired by microorganisms
researchers have developed
various methods for actuation and
navigating for example
bloodstream in human body or or other
organisms for example one day these
robots could deliver some some medicine
to a certain part of the body
notably these robots have not
self-contained actuational mechanism
everything is outside so it's external
actuation or excitation it could be
electromagnetic it could be a heat or
laser
pointing and
and their Mass manufacturing is thanks
to the microfibrication process so they
could be really mass produced in batches
like the Silicon chip
when it comes to the mesoscale again we
would face a challenge of
miniaturization for example
miniaturizing the conventional electric
models is difficult
and also for example manufacturing
multiple components into a single small
package would have another trade-off so
that would actually increase the
complexity of the design as well as the
size of the robot and we would like to
scale these robotic swarms right so we
we need to figure out how we can
fabricate them in batches just like the
micro robots
and I call this problem a 3M problem
and throughout my PhD and here at
Stanford I'm trying to kind of address
scratch the surface of how I can address
this 3M problem
let's look at the how robots were built
in the in a and look at the state of the
art so for swarm robotics we can see
that these robots could be mass produced
thanks to their simple mechanical
designs but they have profound
communication capabilities and obviously
these robots were built to study complex
swarm behaviors
but they were limited to 2D surfaces so
it could be a benefit to
actually include more capability so you
embed more capabilities that these
robots could go to the 3D space
when it comes to the terrestrial multi
Locomotion robots so they are not only
bound to the 2D surface but they can now
achieve 3D locomotion
we can see that they have complex
designs so they use conventional methods
of transmission actuation and other
mechanisms for example it could have a
crawling so they have separate mechanism
paired Locomotion so you can have a
crawling mechanism which is separate
from the jumping mechanism and this
would be hindering their miniaturization
as well as mass manufacturing just
imagine yourself putting together all of
these small three-dimensional components
in a in a meticulous Manner and then try
to kind of scale it up to a larger
swarm or Collective like Behavior
so if you look at the conventional
methods we can see that there is
certainly some challenges so if you like
to for example design it
simple joint so we would have two
kinematic pairs so that would be pin and
socket that would be moving relative to
each other
but we if you would like to motorize it
we would include a motor on the joint
then further if you like to have a high
torque actuation of the link or or the
joint we would
introduce some gears gearboxes to the
motors
and then if you would like to for
example generate a variable power
actuaries we would include a spring
which would we could load it and then
generate variable power actuation
but also if you like to have for example
this continuous power actuation we would
like to generate sudden power output
from the mechanism we would be kind of
loading a spring
charging it storing the potential energy
and then releasing it to convert it to
kinetic energy so which is very useful
for jumping applications for example so
we can see that the complexity actually
increases when we include more
functionality to the design and also
number of components increases so it
could be that it's higher cost more
manufacturing and assembly time
but imagine you have a so-called smart
material
or just a cantilever B let's say here in
the in this example
imagine that under no stimuli it could
be flexible so it could act as a rotary
joint
then you would apply some stimuli
and this joint now start to move
it would have its embedded functionality
in order to generate high torque you
just increase the size of the of the of
the or the thickness of the cantilever
or you could play with the geometry of
the system and then sorry and then you
could vary the stimuli to have the
variable power output or variable torque
output of the system
and you could also play with the
bi-stable nature of these structures so
you could build a structure that could
be by stable and you could Flip or kind
of change between two states
also just imagine now you can have
multiple layers of it built on top of
each other just like a printed circuit
board then you can embed each
functionality in a layer so that you
don't have to assemble three-dimensional
components
so that's how we built the tripod it's a
multi-locka motion uh Milli robot that
can generate jumping crawling and
walking
and these robots are inspired by Trap
giants the mechanism in the middle
actually is is very similar to what Trap
giants have in their jaws so it can open
up its legs to 100 or about 180 degrees
and snap through and close it quickly
the robot weighs about 10 gram and it
can fit on your palm and
maybe half of the
weight and the surface of the robot is
actually take out
it's taken up by the batteries
so let's see how it works
um we can do vertical jumps so on any
other on any three of the edges as well
as we can by changing the actuation
sequence of these shape memory actuators
that I'm going to mention later okay we
can actually jump forward we can also
vary the power to get variable variable
output from The Locomotion mechanism
as well as we can overcome obstacles for
example or even detect stairs so we can
embed sensors on board of this PCB body
and of course we could also do some
athletic behaviors
so why is it important to embed
multi-looking motion for these small
scale animals it's because like if you
look at the small scale animals as long
as they shrink the everything around
them environment becomes bigger and
bigger so they have to cope with this
environment and for example they could
crawl across a kind of flat smooth
surface but then when they have an
obstacle they could jump over the
obstacle so that's how that's what we
would like to show here is that we can
uh transition from crawling to kind of
flip Flack or rolling Locomotion and as
well as jump over the obstacles
simple
and cheap robots is really
um I think beneficial if you could kind
of mass produce them and that could have
very simple let's say
um
Electronics as well as sensing
capabilities but then then with
increasing the number we could basically
create tasks for each and then they
could they could work together instead
of like creating a one sophisticated
robot perhaps and then here for example
we showed that the leader follower
scenario where a leader robot here
continues to scans the environment so
the follower doesn't scan it so it
doesn't spend too much energy on that
and the leader would just let the
follower know that there is an obstacle
coming soon
and I would jump over this Gap
and the follower here would be Computing
how many steps it should crawl before it
it can come to the edge of this Gap and
then jump over it
so there are there is a lot of
possibilities we could do with simple
and kind of low cost and mass
manufactured robots we could distribute
the tasks but this is how it's made so
it's very similar to what how your
iPhone or your Samsung device is
manufactured it's a layer by layer
manufacturing process
but unlike this electronic components uh
devices we we embed mechanical
functionality into the onto the
multi-layer process so you can see here
that we have the pcbs some adhesive and
the captain for example for the joint
and then we also embed shape memory
alloy actuators that I'm going to
discuss later and by kind of sandwiching
all of these components into so-called
quasi to the structure or sandwich we
can fold this sandwich to obtain the
three-dimensional shape of the object so
basically addressing the not only the
structure but also like the
functionality you could embed multiple
materials for different functionalities
and we studied the performance of the
robot so we could I showed you that that
we could change the stimuli so that to
obtain for example to generate different
heights of jumping or the distance of or
we all we also studied the robots
Locomotion performance on like a sloped
or a flat to rate
um so when we look at the cost of
Transport so it's like energetic cost of
Transport is a measure of how much
energy is required for a robot to travel
a certain distance for a specialty
distance jumps we can see that
um on the on the left we see that there
is terrestrial multi-lock motion insect
like the temperature and jumping spider
and desert Locust and we compared that
with tribute and other multiple
commercial robots the tribute could
actually be have a comparable cost of
Transport for example close to Desert
Locust or the jumping spider but
obviously the Trap joints here beats
everyone
um this was yeah obviously this data is
for that uh particular time of frame but
there are also robots now who could
actually generate really high power at
very small scale
and here's the
evolution of the robot so we started
with the origin where we study like 3D
printing methods as well as composite
methods and then we embedded some
sensors onto the to control the step
size The Crawling step size as well as
the jumping height of the robot then we
really embedded all the knowledge into
kind of self-contained robot with and
and later we also studied the cage for
example you noticed that if the robot
would fall on its Edge on one of the
sides it wouldn't be able to continue
its operation because it's just flat on
the on the side so this kind of elliptic
cage helps it to self-ride and then
continues motion and yeah later before I
left epfl
I was involved in work where we were
thinking about really
can we start from 2D and then it would
sell fault and uh and then self-write
itself into 3D and then it would
continue its operation so this kind of
2D assembly process helps us to kind of
maybe sandwich multiple of them and then
kind of deploy and this this kind of
flat robots could self-assemble and then
start moving without kind of storing it
in 3D
so the robotic origami allows us to
embed a lot of kind of functionality and
mechanisms so here we show that this is
the the tripod cage
here we could also embed all of the
components like the self-writing
mechanism in 2D process so you can be
really creative about how you can
generate these three-dimensional
functionalities in 2D and then kind of
manufacture everything in 2D and obtain
that at the end but it could also kind
of have this cage foldable
so you could fold it deploy it would
self-write absorbing some Shock and then
continue its operation
I touched on the fabrication process
from the 2D component to the 3D
structure of the robot but what we
really do in design space is we actually
Define a 3D robot oh and then all its um
a necessary component
and then we basically unfold it
we unfold it to the kind of to this
sandwich and then decompose it to
multiple layers and that's how the
design process works we try to kind of
generalize or provide a kind of more
systematic methods for these approach so
as I mentioned there is a very important
function of the any origami is the
geometry and as well as the mechanisms
that you like to embed in the structure
and materials here is playing very
important role so we put these three
components concurrently rather than
sequentially because for example the
shape of the of a smart actuator that
can bend for example it plays it it's it
plays a big role for example it's
geometry would be very much related to
it because it's I'll show you in a
minute how the the modeling or the
behavior of the of these actuators are
actually related to this geometry also
thermomechanical components and and all
of that together generate this mechanism
so it's kind of a fusion of the three
components that's why we put it in the
concurrent uh process rather than like a
sequential process if you think about
like let's say conventional robot design
you would be probably choosing let's say
a plastic 3D printed plastic or
injection molded Plastics or CNC
machined aluminum for example and that
one is already defined by your
manufacturing processes they might come
at the end of the of the design process
for example but here we
kind of also pay attention to the
fabrication processes based on these
three
components and that's that in this
process is really not definitive at the
end so we have to do some
characterization mechanical and material
characterization at the end of this
sandwich or the decomposed each
component
and we have to refine this design
process so that we could reach
desired results
so at the end I think like a concept or
more like a paradigm we could one day
perhaps build this make this methodology
seem to design tools so you we could
really design like we have Eagle for PCB
design or KitKat and we could
manufacture them with
um embedded manufacturing processes and
then as well as
test them and then customize those
designs according to those tests so
yeah so that was for for the design of
these versatile robots and I like to
talk about
what actuation methods or actuaries that
actually made these robots possible to
move and generate the functionality
so there four types of actuators that I
was studying so one of them is a linear
coil an abandoned sheet and linear wave
so these three actuators were shape
memory alloy or nickel titanium alloy
which you could
basically form them into let's say a
coil
and then anneal it or hit it at high
temperatures and that alloy would
memorize that shape so once you kind of
stretch it and then you apply heat or
you pass a current through it which is
called Joel heating that would be
compressing again kind of to the
memorized shape so you can do this
cyclic
kind of extension and compression of the
actuator to to be used for robots for
example like an artificial muscle
um
so how we so how we actually use this
shape morality actuators the coil in
this case so for example if you like to
have this crawling motion we just need a
smooth continuous
um kind of operation so it's like going
back and forth right so for that we
needed three coils and then we could
activate one in the in the other at the
bottom to close the leg and then
activate the ones on the side to open
the leg so we can basically control it
continuously smoothly but
in order to generate this sudden snap
through mechanism we could still use the
same approach here so
we can open the legs of the robot 100 or
more degrees and then that would and
then we could start activating the
bottom one so that activation creates
actually a compression at the middle
joint
so at some point the the mechanism is
looking for stability point so it snaps
through to the other direction
generating a high torque and that torque
is translated to ground reaction force
that lifts the robot up
um
it was mentioning here is that
you can see here that this shape memory
always bring behavior is quite similar
to the the to the steel spring for
example which behaves according to
hooke's law but one difference here is
that the the shear module is here is a
function of temperature temperature so
because it's a thermally activated
actuator the temperature will Define how
stiff it this uh spring would behave
and then we embedded uh some sensors on
the on board and we used this um
uh actuator and then here we I show here
is that we can basically
modify the power we could we could
modulate the input power to generate
different jumping Heights
and these Springs are actually very kind
of tedious to manufacture you have to
call them up and and also kind of go
through that process so in order to
avoid that we were thinking um can we
actually have a layer of the sheet and
use it for that purpose so but that
would be a kind of a bending rather than
like a linear compression motion so but
the the challenge let's say with this
kind of bending sheet type of actuator
is that
um you wouldn't be able to hit it like
the coil it has a higher resistant
electrical resistance so so in order to
kind of reduce that we Implement like
another layer of heater which would not
directly hit it but conduct the heat to
the actuator
um again it's very similar to a bending
sheet equations so where the elastic
modulus is now as a function of the
temperature and the temperature could be
and that elastic modulus temperature is
a function of called martensic fraction
coefficient I will not go to the details
of the of the equations but basically
their behavior could be non-linear let's
say it could be kind of cosine of sine
function it could be exponential so a
different literature kind of
put it in a different and tried it in
different methods in here we can clearly
see
that our behavior for the actuator is
quite kind of a cosine of sine function
and we embedded these actuaries for
um for for let's say like a flat
sheet of material that could self-fold
and then not only cell phone could be
controlled and and also kind of
transition to other states
uh this one is going from use flat to
u-shape from U shape to let's say
tetrahedral shape
all right so
I mentioned about the coils which are
difficult to manufacture and maybe a
sheet would be easier to manufacture but
the sheet cannot store potential energy
so we would need certainly something
that could be kind of coil-like we could
could store energy more elastic
unlike sheet so we combined both
properties in a flat sheet type of wave
SMA actuator
so the fabrication process is very easy
so you could have a sheet of material
and then you could score this Serpentine
structure on top on onto the
need to know sheet
cut out using the laser and then not
only you could create these kind of
stretchable elements but you could also
stack them so you could create high
Force actuators as well by just kind of
using adhesive and other methods
and we use these actuators for uh
for the case of reconfigurable grip so
what does it do so the reconfigurable
gripper is is a suction gripper and as
you know the suction gripper in the
industry would have fixed shapes so the
amount of or the shape of the objects
they can pick up are really really
limited to their shape but we were
thinking can we actually have
um reconfigurable version of shape
Morpher version of this robot so we
again used origami design methods so you
can see here in the mod 1 it has a
larger aperture and then it could change
its aperture according accordingly by
selectively activating embedded shape
memory alloy actuators
and the manufacturing process is very
simple here that we have some silicon
where we integrating more rigid
components like fiber glass and then we
embed actuator so it becomes a kind of a
single piece of material
and then here uh please note that in the
inside of them we use coil still coil
type of actuators but the actors from
the outside are wave type of actuators
as you can see here is that for example
picking up a very narrow and um long
object like the pen here is is quite
difficult so we can switch to a
different mode and and it's really if
you like to represent uh different like
so many different geometries of this
Apaches and then objects that you want
to pick up
you can you can really play with origami
structures and then how this these
structures could could generate those
shapes
and this this actuator that I want to
present is quite kind of different from
the shape memory Alloys but it has
benefits so this is based on fluidics so
it's pneumatic
one of the challenges of the shape
memory actuators is uh their speed or
the bandwidth they're quite slow
but pneumatics we know that it can be
quite fast so and we were thinking all
right can we design different types of
robots but could also be behaving or or
reconfiguring or configuring to
different shapes really fast and that's
how we come up with the idea of kind of
embedded fluidic Chambers so what it
does is you could embed fluidic channels
for example in this mirror Ori origami
pattern
you can see there is Mountain Mountain
and Valley fold and then you can design
those folds to have some fluidic
Chambers if you suck the air out from
these Chambers some of them would be
collapsing and this collapse would
generate some fault
so that's the basic idea of the of the
of the structure
so as you can see here
by having a single port
you can distribute all of that actuation
onto the 2D surface
and you can design it to be mountain or
Valley you could also design it to be
having different moment
or Torque generated at their fault
what we also noticed that by
changing what for example by altering
the fluidic chamber so the cross-section
area of the fluidic channels you could
also have certain delay in certain
actuation response so we use that delay
actually that to generate kind of
sequential folding Behavior with these
structures
yeah that's pretty much summarized that
multi-layer multi-material processes
really could
um speed up and enable us to have kind
of mispreducible multifunctional robot
and next I would like to actually touch
on the next application which I'm I'm
actually involved here at Stanford it
was very exciting for me is to see
different challenges in different
robotic Fields where this kind of
approach could be applied
so as you know
um
haptic interfaces could enable us to
interact with the digital environment it
could be a virtual world a metaverse or
any other definition of the the system
so in this three-dimensional virtual
world we would like to have
compelling realistic intuitive
interaction behaviors so in order to be
touching something
you you should for example when you
interact with the physical world for
example touching this bottle when you
pick it up
he basically would feel what's the
weight of the object for example there
are multiple sensors in your body one of
them is mechanoreceptors that tell you
um how how heavy is this object and one
of them is like for example you would
feel the friction
another thing for example does the
bottle rotate in your hand you could
also kind of fill it by rotational
friction or you could also feel how soft
is the bottle so all of that
multi-model information is processed in
your brain but picked up by the
mechanoreceptors so this
mechanoreceptors provide kind of
information on different attributes of
the object could be texture it could be
rigidity it could be weight and so on
and the haptic devices that were
developed for these cases is mostly for
example for a fingertip which is the
most sensitive area of our hand for
touch and
these fingertip devices could generate
different degrees of freedom of motion
so degrees of freedom basically you
could imagine that it is like how
complex
attributes of the object we could
recreate or how complex it could be the
interaction Behavior so for example if
you go from left to right you see that
the three degrees of freedom was was um
was we have the three degrees of freedom
kind of haptic device that were inspired
by conventional
um Panther or or
parallel robot systems in the industry
and then kind of basically trying to
miniaturize them into a small footprint
but we also see that we have four
degrees of freedom using some origami
but using again some conventional
actuation methods so really for me was
again coming back to the 3M problem can
we actually address it using the same
methods that I was presenting earlier
and that's how we I start working the
fingerprint so fingerprint is a fully 3D
printed haptic device so it requires
zero assembly process and embeds four
degrees of freedom capability so it can
stretch your skin it can provide
pressure vibrations and it's really
monolithic so you can design it in one
piece print it in one piece and then
by kind of cleaning post processing of
this 3D printed piece you could
have it ready for uh for your
application
so how it works
you have a single piece of material with
embedded actuators readily in the system
some fluidic channels and
and also the the mechanism is again uses
some origami that I'm going to show you
later
so this tactor interacts with your
fingertip
giving you four degrees of freedom
interaction in stimulation
you can change the frequency of the of
the stimuli so that you can have for
example vibration you could also have
faster interaction our interaction is
not really
um kind of
the same bandwidth so we have a kind of
varying frequencies when we interact so
it could be for example for a finer
objects that you want to know the the
texture about it could be higher
frequencies or more coarse objects would
have lower frequencies and so on
yeah so
the main thing in the body of the of the
fingerprint is this origami mechanism or
water bomb based mechanism
it is of eight uh foldable actuators and
these foldable lectures are basically
again like a Chambers but now 3D printed
and by applying uh some vacuum to these
Chambers and selectively through these
fluidic channels we can make this tactor
in the middle move in the desired
Direction
and here is the origami mechanism it's a
water bomb base this mechanism can
generate three degrees of freedom so by
for example if you change the angle of
the folds here on the creases you can
generate different motion on the
attacker so but since our device is
pretty soft when we actuate all of these
faults together it compress and
generates the pressure and that's how we
achieve the four degrees of freedom
which is not defined by this origami
mechanism
and yeah it's really
easy to kind of mass produce a skeleton
in a single printing process
and some of the key considerations
obviously is to think about how you
would design the
um the the support where would you like
to install them because this is a soft
material and we are using very thin
layers of
um thin layers for for example the
actuator walls so we would like to kind
of have a right amount of let's say
support and but also we would want to be
able to remove them later after it was
processing so that it's not very Labor's
procedure
yeah and I think key
takeaways from here is really um that we
could change the vacuum pressure to gen
to actually control the force output of
this tractor for example here we can see
that the tractor can move
and kind of generate different forces
for example for the pressure Z Force
by just changing the input fluidic
pressure
so it gives us another dimension where
we could do maybe close loop control
um and I further extended this method to
risk for a device so unlike risk like
the fingertip device responding device
allows you to kind of uh place
um more components so generate kind of
display like
um capability on the wrist because there
is so much real estate on the wrist
rather than on the fingertip
so this this device can generate about
20 newtons of force which is quite High
and
again we here we use a little slightly
different method so we use Bellow type
of actuators that can compress when you
apply a vacuum and by selectively
activating these Bellows the tactor in
the middle here can generate different
motions and I can show you this motion
here sorry
so detector here generates You by
playing
um you know so by kind of activating
these actuators in different manner this
texture can be for example applying
Shear in X Direction y or it could even
apply like a Twist motion or stretch
your skin or as well as squeeze so by
scaling up this number of
huxels for example on on your skin you
could generate like a display like
haptic interaction
yeah so we're currently
studying this fingerprint on the on the
on the phalange for example which is
called the haptic relocation one of the
challenges with having it on the
fingertip is really the physical
interaction between fingers when you're
trying to grasp small virtual objects
for example in order to
we are currently using this devices to
be relocated to the as a ring for
example and use that
to understand how people perceive or how
effective it is on the on the phalange
for example
and also we are generating this kind of
modular
displays with these huxels where we
could kind of put them not only like in
One Direction but we could put in the
opposite we could scale them so many of
them on the skin and then have more
input
yeah and other projects as Mark
mentioned I work with Crystal
um on this fluid actuated four degrees
of freedom origami mechanism which can
be fabricated in a 2d and you basically
obtain the three-dimensional shape of
the uh robot and also like a twisted
string type of actuation so here we
again we also study like 3D printing
with more rigid materials and then we
use it for its compliance to control its
motion
yeah with that I would like to thank all
of my collaborators and colleagues from
epfl as well as at Stanford and yeah
yeah moving forward I think we could
build this massive scale or miniature
robots
that could be interacting with your body
with the environment or with themselves
and we could also generate so much
capability with these designs yeah thank
you so much
[Applause]
I'll ask a question about other people
think about it so one of the things
that's sort of always
um
interested and maybe concerned me a
little bit about the origami robotics
going to smaller scales is that we
we don't get perfect hinge joints we we
have flexors and the smaller we get the
more true that is
and what should we you know is there
something we can do about that or is it
or do we just live with it and live with
the fact that there will be this more
complicated motion with side effects
yeah that's a great question yeah I
think the form factor in scaling really
plays a role here
um obviously like micro mechanical
systems field they use a lot of this
flexure type of joints because it's much
easier to manufacture them at that scale
but mesoscale
um I would say they're good enough but
not really like
um perfect as as a pin and socket joint
they deform but some of the let's say
results they show the characterization
and kind of quite good results but uh I
think yeah we have to be careful about
like
um it really depends on the on the let's
say the gap size of the hinges or the
the structure of the or the material
itself which which I mentioned earlier
so yeah so
I think there is some potential there
where we don't need High Precision
applications for example haptics could
be one of them because the human
perception is not that accurate let's
say to precisely
feel 50 Micron versus 100 Micron or even
I think millimeters so it's it's really
I think important to define the scale
and kind of application scenario for
them
yeah I think there's one question there
all right I guess since he was a little
bit faster all right so one kind of
general question from the zoom is what
got you interested in making these types
of robots in the first place
well yeah
um
I think the overall idea let's say of
materials for example I previously in my
Master's I was working in this
piezoelectric actuators that was the
starting point I think when I was kind
of very much excited about material
field as well in kind of including in my
expertise so
um
and origami and the design itself really
excites me so
combining all of them was was really
something that I wanted to work on and
yeah that's how I started my journey at
epfl great thank you
okay there's two thank you first in your
second
oh how much does a 3D printing one
origami cost
a cost
uh the 3D printed haptic device yeah
um
it's a great question I haven't
calculated it I don't have the precise
number but
um given
uh I think it's it's a commercially
available 3D printer which costs 3500
which is not very expensive I would say
like many people use it and it's very
precise 50 Micron accuracy which printer
is it it's form Labs form labs and I use
their available cartridge which is 200
per cartridge per tank
um even not pertangular cartridge and
that lasts me to print I don't know
hundreds of pieces right so it's a 200
400 so maybe dollars
a few dollars yeah
um are there any like specific
applications you were keeping in mind
when designing the um the finger print
yeah yeah that's a great question yeah
so one application is really like have
three-dimensional Mouse right or
keyboard in Virtual environment so when
we have the headset everything visual is
three-dimensional
and our interaction should be
accordingly kind of more like more
intuitive so that one way is like having
a device in your hand a headset and you
would be kind of touching the
environment let's say clicking the
button so clicking the button even like
needs to be done properly right so there
is a recoiling of the spring that you do
and then the texture or for example if
it is hot if it is cold surface so all
of that should
potential should be included in this
device so I mean in reality you would be
touching the the space this the air
right but that would give you a feeling
if you are touching the real object yeah
so that's one of them and another thing
I think is skill transfer in an
education
so for example you could surgeons could
do thousands of this
training hours in Virtual environment
without dealing with
a real objects or real tools so that
would give them a lot of possibilities
to learn
um I'm always curious when you know
researchers pull up images of ants and
stuff like that like where where do
people Benchmark all these you know
insects and organisms where do people
find all these you know small details of
their anatomy and and use that for
inspiration is there you know some
University that's done some papers about
that and that's what people just build
off of or yeah yeah
that's a great question I'm not a
biologist or or I am what I what I did
was
um I saw a video
um it was about the paper which which
some biologists were studying their
behavior and I went in and found so many
papers actually in biology and I started
to reading about them so that's how I
think it's usually done is there is a
lot of done by researchers and you could
kind of uh build on on top of that I
think yeah that was my experience at
least
thanks
um yeah to just to add and I also kind
of reached out to some biologists and we
also discussed like how they usually
work and because they were like experts
in that field
um thank you for the presentation I was
just wondering
if you see potential applications for uh
macro scale versions of the Trap jaw
robots or any of the robots we talked
about
yeah
um is um
I mean for haptic devices I think it's
kind of kind of clears that we we wanted
to be advancing uh let's say the
training process we wanted to be used
maybe in the next generation of digital
interaction
um
for I don't know consumer devices or it
could be for more specific training and
skill transfer for I mean
the device so there is like multiple
things so one is to for for trap Joanne
type of robots for example one way is to
have this artificial
um
capabilities is to really maybe
understand these natural systems as well
how they behave so it's kind of but also
like if we emulate those systems we
could have
in the future potential like for
interplanetary exploration like we could
deploy them in mass and then
really not be dependent on single
sophisticated multi-billion dollar
machine
maybe that that could be the future of
it
if there is one otherwise out close it
and thank you oh one more okay
I'm just curious about the plot it was
kind of near the beginning just about
um the uh mass and energy usage of each
so what are the fundamental constraints
um because it looked like there's still
a big gap between what ants can do and
and
um what we can do with robots what are
the fundamental constraints preventing
us to get down to the mass levels of the
ants
yeah I think that's a great question and
I was always asking me this question
right
um I think it's artificially recreating
uh these structures probably we could
recreate the structure but like muscles
and all of that is really so difficult
to recreate with artificial means so
um I mean ideally we would have this
muscle right but then is it
um we have to put it into let's say
um more moisture uh environment and so
on so there are researchers who are
actually working on kind of taking this
muscle and need to be used for these
kind of cases but again there's so many
challenges of like keeping those muscles
alive like keeping them moisturized or
or
um yeah so but as you saw like in macro
world we generate this electromechanical
hydraulic actuator Metals which are
quite effective and could be much more
powerful than elephant or whale right
but again it's the same thing can we do
more with artificial rather than like
replicating exactly
[Applause]